hey everyone it's Michael BOS here from
orderflows decom and here is the
orderflows market analysis for April 13
2017 I apologize I haven't been able to
get many videos up over the last last
month or so actually I've been extremely
extremely busy schedule I've been
traveling all over the world actually I
have now settled back in the Philippines
for at least the immediate future uh by
that I mean at least the uh next 3 to 6
months and I hope to get more videos out
for everybody I've got a webinar coming
up on April 19th so you know the link
will be down in
the description so you can go there and
sign up for it but before I get started
again the brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures training contains St so risk and
it's not for every investor and inventor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
there's a reason why we have a
disclaimer um well one the government
requires it but you know the reason they
require it is because people come to the
trading world with high expectations
they think they're going to be become
multi-millionaires in I mean some seem
to think in in a week but realistically
you know trading is hard you know and
you can't just go out and always think
you can buy you know some trading system
that promis going to make you thousands
of dollars every trading day trading is
work you know there there is um no
business in the world that you could
just step into and start printing money
tomorrow you know you have to do your
research you have to do due diligence
you have to do everything and at the end
of the day you have to do the work now
you know I get people coming to me
thinking really that orderflow is the
way that's going to change their trading
literally overnight that they have to do
no extra work to it all they got to do
is pull up the chart but you know what
at the end of the day you have to
understand what you're looking at I mean
you could have the best charting
software in the world but if you don't
know what you're doing then you know
it's kind of pointless it's it's similar
to buying you know a high performance
SPS car if if you don't know how to
drive drive it properly you know how to
um you know use everything in in the car
then it's going to be worthless you know
it's like buying one of those fancy DSLR
cameras you know for um you know $1,000
$2,000 and just using it in automatic
mode but what you know what orderflow
teaches you how to do is it teaches you
how to think right we all in this day
and age everybody wants to have
everything automated let the computer do
all the work you know I mean at the end
of the day the best Traders are the ones
that make their own trading decisions
yes there are Exceptions there are
companies out there hedge funds that are
fully automated you know Renaissance you
know it's all backed by rocket
scientists you know doing the research
and you know top level programmers but
for everyday people you know we don't
have those resources that you know don't
think for a minute that you could just
sit down and you know code something up
you know maybe one person out of out of
a million can do that but for the rest
of the human world it's just not
possible but what orderflow trading
teaches you to do it teaches you how to
read the market how to understand what's
going on you know people can learn how
to trade properly just as you can teach
a dog tricks you know how you can learn
to play the guitar you can learn to
trade it's it's up to you if you want to
do it and put in the time
and you know get the education to do it
but if you think you're just going to
sit down and tomorrow you know become an
expert Trader um simply because you have
a a footprint chart on on your screen no
that that's not going to happen now I I
know that that's a bit harsh you know I
I sell software to help Traders but you
know I I I don't want people coming to
me thinking that this is you know the
Holy Grail to trading will it help your
trading yes it will but also at the end
of the day you have to put in the work
you know you're the one that has to
figure out um you know how to get your
system up and running how to go to the
ninja Trader website and download their
software and get it running on your
computer um you know I I know people
really want in this day and age
everything done for them and you know at
the end of the day you have to learn how
to use a computer um I mean as as basic
as that sounds there's Traders out there
they they don't want to take to learn
take the time to learn I mean you know
who do you want to operate on you do you
want somebody that you know is was you
know a slacker in medical school or
somebody that you know really hit the
books and and did their studying did
their
experimentations did their practice you
know in the hospitals you know that
that's that's what you want you know you
want someone that's taking the
initiative and that's what you need to
do also you need to also take initiative
in in your trading so the tools that I
use in this presentation today is the
order flows Trader footprint chart
and you know it for those that aren't
familiar with it real quick you know
it's a volume footprint chart it it
shows you the volume trade on the bid
volume traded on the offer and it's from
there that you make your trading
decisions so without further Ado let
let's jump in and you know real quick
I'll just show you a few examples today
I'm also getting back used to recording
videos I said I've been off my normal
schedule I massive case of jet leg
flying on a lot of flights in a short
period of time and sometimes you know
I'm talking and and words come out of my
mouth I don't even realize what I'm
saying sometimes um because I'm I'm so
exhausted that I I listen to myself and
I said did I just say that but anyway
euro currency this is from Thursday the
this is today is Saturday the day ahead
of Easter so this was uh Thursday there
there was markets were closed on
Friday so what do we got here um this is
what the software does you have a low
here you have a ratio right my my
software I know I'm the one that came
out with with the ratios other people
are adopting it but you
know if they don't know how to use it
properly what's the point of putting it
in their software and giving it out to
you um I'm going to be creating another
video on on how to use the ratios
because you know a lot of people are
getting bad information on how to use
them
but you know I have the information
already for the users but you know for
for non-users I I don't I'd rather them
not get shitty information
and it's going to cost them money okay
at the end of the day I don't mind that
other people are taking my ideas and
putting in their software I do wish they
would give me credit you know honestly
um you know I'm the first one maybe I'm
not the first one that came up with it I
mean maybe there was one other person
using it but as far as I know I'm I'm
the first one that's you know I've been
using it in my trading for for years and
I'm the first one to actually put it in
the in the footprint chart um you know
to help you make your analysis easier
because you know you see a footprint
chart you see a lot of numbers and and
you know people get fixed on numbers and
they get scared everybody hates math you
know and why they hate math because they
hate numbers so you know we use what I
created were these ratios which I
actually used to do in my head or
sometimes on a on a calculator but you
know it got to the point where I could
just look at it and see what the ratio
was in a bar whether it's bullish or
bearish if it's bullish it's underneath
if it's bearish it's on top if it's a
black
number it's neutral okay so on a green
bar the ratio is going to be
underneath and if it's a ratio I like
it's going to be blue if it's a ratio
that's neutral it's going to be black if
it's a ratio I like on a red bar it's
going to be above the red bar and it's
going to be in blue if it's just a
neutral ratio it's going to be in Black
so anyway one of the things my software
does is when you have imbalances at the
bottom of a green bar it's going to draw
an arrow it sounds very simple yes do
you need fancy software to do it no but
what my software does is it highlights a
lot of things in the order flow to you
so that it frees up your mind to look at
other things so you he draws the Green
Arrow here so you know that you know you
have an imbalance here which is very
bullish in the short term and you can as
you can see we went from 106 uh 45 46
all the way up to you know 10660 in a
very quick period of time okay right
here you know these are what I call
the slam dunk trades are they 100%
always happen and move in that direction
no but a very high percentage of the
time they work and it's best in the
short term don't think you're going to
be buying it here at 906 and holding it
3 days no you you're buying it here at
906 yeah you may be holding it for an
hour max 2
hours extreme maximum really you're just
looking for the the very short popup and
you know 908 you're getting in you know
9:15 it's still sort of hang around
break even then the move happens you
know just after 9:30 um again you go
from the 106 46 you know at least up to
56 within um the next 15
minutes okay so the next thing I want to
talk about is the bonds all right and
again you have a swing low here or low
of the day actually you have a
Divergence you have a positive Delta on
a new or equal low you got your bar
turning up so the price action in the
bar is bullish which is what you want to
see I mean you don't want to just be
taking blind divergences everywhere down
you also want to have confirmation in
the bar that the market is starting to
turn up secondly you have a ratio you
like right it's a green bar so you're
looking for the ratio underneath it's
34.9 6 it's a blue number I'm not so
fixated on the actual numbers really
what I'm looking at is is it blue or is
it black if it's blue it's a go if it's
black it's just your average your
average bar so you got a nice move you
know from this low you know this is the
low of the day at this point it's uh
15311 you know wait for confirmation
wait for the bar to close you know
people like to get um I say greedy but
you know they they get excited they see
they see this happening you see a
Divergence you see a ratio you like and
you want to get in on the bar but you
know it's lots of times the bar is still
trading and what looks bullish all of a
turns bearish and the bar keeps you know
Market keeps selling off so you're all
of a sudden you're you're trying to get
an early entry thinking you're going to
save a couple ticks and in the end the
trade's not there and you're sitting on
a loser you know it's it's worth waiting
for confirmation waiting for the bar to
close and even if you got to give up two
or three ticks it's it's worth it rather
than sitting on a loss that you
shouldn't even have so you know you can
be getting in at uh 15315
15316 and you know it made a nice move
all the way up into the 20s you know
then just sort of went sideways on you
before keep going up again I'm not I'm
not looking to to get long here at 908
and necessarily hold it all the way up
to uh you know to 12 um before it starts
selling off I mean you know some people
may do that I I don't I definitely don't
recommend that if if you're trading a
four range chart four range is is kind
of a short term okay the next thing I
want to talk about is the e- minis um
this is a 10 range chart so it's a bit
of a longer duration chart and look at
what's happened up here at at these
highs um this was again this was on
Thursday the 13th and we're hitting the
highs you have a Divergence up here you
got a new high this is a 10 range chart
you got a new high you got a strong
negative Delta 2,600 you have a
Divergence next bar again negative Delta
then you just go sideways in here um you
know strong positive Delta followed by
kind of a smallish positive Delta a
small negative Delta and then you got
positive Delta a new high by a tick you
got positive Delta positive Delta in
these two bars now it's
interesting you have positive Deltas
with red bars well you know what does
that tell you it's telling you that
early in the bar there was some strong
buying late in the bar the selling came
in and the selling took over the bar and
since it's a 10 range chart you know
there might not have been enough volume
as you're moving down to get out to turn
it to negative um negative Delta then
all of a sudden you see the negative
Delta really picking upus 3,000 - 4,000
as you start selling off but you know
the first sign that may maybe this this
High might not hold is the first time
you hit the high you had a very strong
negative Delta okay then it just sort of
hung around up here made this new high
on smaller positive Delta you're going
up you have this bar here 1,800 900 and
then it's getting lesser 927 and then -
3,000 you know it's I don't want to say
it's safe to say but the odds are now
selling is taken over right because you
see the bars turning down Delta early in
the Bars were strong it was 2000 you
know the max Delta tells you how strong
the Delta was in that bar before um you
know and during that bar so at one point
it was positive 2,420 8 ended up at only
977 the next bar positive 3,800 only
ended up at 927 and then selling just
really took over there was no more
buying minus 3,000 minus
45,000 you know at that point you know
it's it you should really be thinking
hey we're not going back up to new highs
and instead looking to get short and if
you're looking to get short you know
you're looking to get short somewhere
around 38 you know you know in here even
um you know 30 in this bar 38 38 in this
bar for sure and you know we sell off
from 38 straight down into new lows you
get a bounce up here uh make new lows
down to 30 and a half and you know
eventually 30 and a quarter was the low
now I'm not saying you're going to be
buying it down here at 30 and a quarter
you know realistically off this little
bounce they short at 38 and it bounces
up a little bit you know if you could
cover around 33 that would be a a
fivepoint move you know Five Points you
know on on a one lot is great if you're
train a five lot even better you know
but anytime you can grab Five Points out
of the market in the snps that's a great
trade you know I know a lot of people
you know trade with domes and and all
that they're they're just looking to get
the next two or three ticks yeah that's
all well and good what would you rather
get would you rather get ticks or points
you know I always as bous you know look
to get look to get um points rather than
ticks and then you know later you got a
new low you got a Divergence you got a a
ratio that you like you know that's
different than this low it's black
number and no Divergence but here you
got the positive Delta you've got the
ratio you get a little of a move um but
then you you run into a bearish ratio
and then it starts coming down you know
during the cash so at best you know
maybe you would have just scratched that
trade and then the day
ended so you
hopefully you watch this video you can
pick up a few things about order at
least maybe it'll Peak your interest
hopefully it'll jog some things in your
mind that will make sense to you you
know to learn more about trading
software using this presentation and how
you can profit from orderflow visit my
website www. orderflows
docomo investor
inspiration um the sign up link will be
in the description below so thanks
everyone and hope to see you on
Wednesday or hope you come to eny our
website and learn more bye-bye